[Musik]
wir wünschen guten appetit
augen auf bei ja wir hoffen es schmeckt
dir du hast ja sicher keine lust mehr
auf deutsches essen oder ich finde
deutsches essen sehr lecker ich mag
wurst und rouladen und gulasch aber am
liebsten mag ich bei do muss zuerst
probieren
schmeckt wie in spanien das ist ein
großes kompliment spanisches essen muss
ich manchmal das verstehe ich hast du
ein bisschen heimweh ein ja ein wenig
das ist wenn man traurig ist und nach
hause möchte
achso nein ich habe kein heimweh mir
gefällt es hier aber meine freunde von
mir sicher ein bisschen und das wetter
in spanien das besser es regnet nicht so
oft gut es werden
ich gehe gleich in jahres laden und
gießt die blumen bis zum mitkommen ja
gerne okay aber ist erst auf